this is the Joo underground podcast
number 82 sitting with Echo
Charles also me here my name is Joo
willink um here's a question that I
posed the other day and as soon as I ask
you this question you're going to think
you're going to know the answer and it's
G to it's going to be one of those
things where you go yep here's the
question if you don't follow the rules
do you get more or less
rules mhm and this is like another
interpretation of discipline equals
Freedom that's what it is it's another
freedom but my original angle on it on
asking this question came from not
thinking about discipline equals freedom
but I was working with some working with
some people working with a company they
have workers the workers have a lot of
freedom in this particular company
there's not a lot of supervision people
out there on their own doing their own
thing kind of and some people take
advantage of it and they're not doing
what they're supposed to be doing in
some cases but it's really hard to track
maybe they take the extra long lunch
break maybe they leave a little early
maybe they show up late maybe they're
not doing the procedures that they're
supposed to be
doing and so guess what happens like
like these things start to show up and
then what does corporate start to do
well corporate then starts imposing
rules and then what
happens you know there's like
um these days you can you can track
people like in a multitude of ways
technology you can I if if you worked
for me and we were a software company I
could monitor your activity on your
computer all day and be like hey you you
know you were on your computer you only
were active on your keyboard for this
many things you only put in this many
characters there was there was an an
hour and an hour and 48 minutes in the
afternoon where you didn't you didn't
input any characters what were you doing
right yeah what were you doing or what
if you were law
enforcement and now I'm tracking you
with a GPS and I'm like oh from you know
1:00 in the afternoon until
3:48 you were in this parking lot in the
back corner of this parking lot what
were you doing how were you helping John
Q
public right so I can start tracking you
now I can start putting on rules yeah
and now how do you feel now you're
getting frustrated
right now you feel like I'm watching you
you feel like I'm micromanaging you and
I am why is that well it's because you
were violating some stuff so as I'm
talking to this
company I ask I ask that question to the
workers to the to the Frontline troops I
said let me ask you a
question if you don't follow the rules
do you get more or less rules and you
could see the their faces kind of
like he's got a point there you do but
here's the thing it's every everyone
knows the answer to that question if you
don't follow the rules do you get more
or less rules the answer is of course
you're going to get more rules that's
what's going to happen and you've been
experiencing this since you were a
kid when you were a kid and you broke a
rule you didn't get less rules you got
more
rules when you're a kid and you your
grades go down you get more rules you
have mandatory homework time You' got
study hall you have to go to if you're
causing problem at recess you get more
rules oh you're not allowed to go to
recess you got to sit here write your
name write the I will not you know push
Freddy around the playground anymore you
got to write that on the board a
thousand times you're going to get more
rules if you break more rules you get
more rules same thing as an
employee or a team member it's the same
thing if you break more rules you get
more rules actually I told them about
the Marine Corp now you know I love the
Marine Corp yes I do
Marine Corps is freaking
outstanding if you go to a Marine Corps
range a lot of
rules they you know hey you will now
Lock and Load five rounds in your weapon
ready on the left ready on the right you
will now fire one round at a time at
your target at 40
m stand by on the left standby on the
right commence firing everyone fires
five rounds ceasefire cease fire you go
to a seal range there's just like no
rules of course there's rules very
limited rules why is that well in the
Marine Corps at some
point somebody shot you know outside the
field of fire so they made a rule M
somebody shot too early they made a rule
somebody shot too late they made a rule
Somebody went Full Auto when they
weren't supposed to they made a rule
somebody snuck some rounds off the range
when they were done they made a
rule somebody wasn't shooting the right
targets they made a rule
so they end up making all these
rules and you're getting controlled
that's what happens you become less
effective actually but why is that it's
because people broke the rules and so
they put rule more rules in place if
you're a human being it's the same
thing if you break rules or more
commonly as a just a human if you don't
have
rules you're going to get
ruled this is the discipline equals
Freedom this is another angle on
discipline equals Freedom that is why
what we have to do as people is give
ourselves rules you have to give
yourself rules to follow you have
to you have to wake up you have to wake
up early in the morning you have to work
out you got to take that cold
shower you got to get your work done for
your job you got to do that well the
better you do that the more more freedom
you're going to get hey if you're
getting micromanaged at work do
better if you feel like you don't have
control over your own destiny do better
you'll get more control be more
productive the more productive you are
the more freedom you're going to get at
work guaranteed it's
guarantee limit the amount set some
rules on the amount of time you're
spending looking at a
screen put rules on that otherwise that
screen's going to rule
you
put rules in play eat clean what are you
doing put some rules around what you're
putting into your
body put rules in
place if you're just doing whatever
you're going to have problems the food
is going to rule
you go to bed on time go to sleep when
you spoke time to go to
sleep and if you follow these
rules that you make for yourself you're
going to have less things in life ruling
you you know when you work hard enough
eventually you don't have a boss anymore
you're Your Own
Boss when you make enough
money eventually that money is not on
your mind anymore it's not ruling your
life you're not worried about how you're
going to afford the
rent the money's not ruling you anymore
when you work
hard when you're healthy you're not
ruled
by disease you're not ruled by
fatigue if you rule
yourself with
discipline you will end up with more
rules which will in fact give you
Freedom so there you go
those are my thoughts for the
day another angle same
gig all right it's a good one man mhm
it's a good one it's uh the look on
their face when I asked that
question that is a little excerpt of
what we are doing on the Joo underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen go to Joo underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us strengthen this
Legion of Troopers that are in the game
with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it costs
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you
mobilized
Underground